live rein in das was dort passiert
können schon mal kurz etwas atmosphäre
aufnehmen sie kennen die dramatische
diskussion um waffenlieferungen für die
ukraine im moment entschieden durch eine
panzerlieferung in die ukraine das wird
jetzt noch mal heftig diskutiert im
deutschen bundestag die parteichefs die
fraktionschefs sie werden sich dort
heute austauschen und so weit da was
spannendes passiert geben wir für sie da
natürlich auch rein ins parlament in den
deutschen bundestag und jetzt geht's
erst mal um einen agentenaustausch
wirklich wie im kalten krieg muss man
sagen russen gegen amerikaner sie
tauschen ihre agenten aus ja eigentlich
ist sowas doch längst geschichte schauen
sie doch mal das war stoff für große
filme so einen agentenaustausch wie hier
bridge of spice mit tom hanks die brücke
der agenten der spione agentenaustausch
auf der glienicker brücke in potsdam
diese historischen szenen dort
nachgespielt das sind alles erinnerungen
hier filme star gestellt die jetzt aber
doch wieder realität werden er denn
jetzt jetzt kommt man kann wirklich
sagen die neuauflage von
wirtschaftspreis und zwar so
gefangenenaustausch zwischen russen und
amerikanern hier vor wenigen stunden
schauplatz ist ein flug rollfeld in der
türkei verliert sie sehen dass auf
beiden seiten der amerikaner trevor räte
sind diese moment frei aus russischer
gefangenschaft und der russe konstantin
jaroschenko der kommt an im gegenzug aus
dem us knast wieder nach russland ein
deal ist das und das mitten in diesen
zeiten in diesen kriegszeiten während
dahinter steckt diese story die story
von trevor ried ein früherer us marine
soldat offizier seit 2009 10 im
russischen gefängnis im straflager wegen
eines angeblichen überfalls auf
polizisten und widerstands gegen die
russiche staatsgewalt in betrunkenem
zustand so heißt das hat er eingestand
nur dass herr immer hoch umstritten und
die usa haben wir immer gesagt dass
alles stimmt nicht also jetzt dieser
deal der amerikaner gegen den russen
pawel ried gegen konstantin jaroschenko
rechts und der saß wegen
drogenschmuggels verurteilten us knast
viele viele viele jahre ist ein früherer
russischer pilot jetzt der
gefangenenaustausch der beiden in der
türkei das also sind die bilder und
schau den an diesen mann reid gebrochen
der 30 jahre alt der kann selbst kaum
mehr laufen wird gestützt dort auf dem
rollfeld in istanbul wo er dann jetzt
nach hause geflogen wird also ein happy
end davon mag man kaum sprechen wenn man
ihn da so gebrochen und gestützt sieht
diesen eigentlich jungen mann diesen us
marine offizier jetzt dank dieses
gefangenenaustausch also wieder dann
bald zurück in den usa und der us
präsident joe biden der schmückt sich
damit das ist sein erfolg also er heißt
ihn willkommen wieder den cherry zurück
in den usa und er freut sich natürlich
mit der familie und sagt mensch das sind
good news zurück der schäfer in der
freiheit darüber wo wir jetzt sprechen
mit ja mit unserem korrespondenten mit
herbert bauernebel uns jetzt
zugeschalteten dass herbert ist ja
wirklich eine besonderheit dieser
gefangenenaustausch in zeiten des
krieges
wie reagiert amerika jetzt auf diesen
deal auf die freilassung von xarita
insgesamt waren das verbrechen für beide
die eigentlich fernab der spionage szene
wirken aber gleichzeitig natürlich diese
bilder aus der türkei erinnern
tatsächlich an diese großen hollywood
filme 2 privat jets nebeneinander die
gefangenen werden ausgetauscht oft
referees familie ist das natürlich ein
moment auf den sie sich so sehr gesehnt
haben es gab wirkliche bedenken
bezüglich seiner haftstrafe essen hat
der berichte gegeben dass ribery im
russischen straflager blut gespuckt
hätte dass er einen hungerstreik
begonnen hat das sagen die songs zustand
sich verschlechtert hätten die eltern
sagten auch in amerikanischen medien
dass sie mit ihm telefoniert hätten er
sich aber ganz anders angehört hätte
hier spürt man doch ganz deutlich dass
hier etwas passiert ist während dieser
haft in russland aber natürlich wird joe
biden ist es ein erfolg das ist für
jeden präsidenten amerikanischen
präsidenten eine große sache amerikaner
einzuholen und man muss dazu sagen
solche diplomatischen
gefangenenaustausch sind in
friedenszeiten schon extrem schwierig
geschweige denn von zeiten wo der
amerikanische präsident im russischen
als kriegsverbrecher bezeichnet und
moskau amerika droht mit atomwaffen so
gesehen ist das wirklich ein
herausragendes ereignis ein wirklich
große diplomatische korps der beiden
seiten hier eigentlich gelungen ist
während über den sich natürlich us
präsident joe biden freut wenn wir
einmal rein was er dazu zu sagen hat
sprecher martin kopp holland
ganz kurz der us-präsident dort auf dem
gang gefragt bei einer veranstaltung
eignet sagte herbert
ja wie gesagt er möchte sich das alles
auf seine fahnen heften es wäre einer
der wenigen erfolge die ja gerade zu
verzeichnen hat bezüglich auch der
politik gegenüber dass keine kriege so
gesehen erfreut sich hier joe biden
hofft darauf dass er politisch punkten
kann und ein bisschen ablenken kann von
der tatsache dass ihm viele amerikaner
hierfür eher schwach erhalten im
showdown gegen russland kann so ein
teilhaber der braucht natürlich einiges
an vorbereitung da passiert ist nicht
einfach so über nacht lasst uns einmal
schauen wann dieser dir seine anfänge
nahm das war bereits im letzten sommer
in genf nämlich da haben sich joe biden
und vladimir putin damals noch die hand
geschüttelt eine szene die hier warst du
denkbaren denkbar heute ist das war also
im vergangenen sommer und da nahm dieser
deal dieser gefangenenaustausch seine
anfänge da hat man zum allerersten mal
darüber gesprochen über das was heute
ein ende fand herbert
ja natürlich bei solchen delikten
austauschen sind lange verhandlungen
nötig man muss dazu sagen
dieser fall wird so erfreulicher geendet
hat betrifft jetzt nicht die weiteren
beziehungen zwischen russland und
amerika bezüglich es auch keine krieg
ist und auch bezüglich anderer
gefangenen schicksal es ist er nach wie
vor in haft britney kreiner eine
amerikanische basketballspielerin eine
berühmte spielerinnen die für einen
russischen klub gespielt hat um die
wegen drogenhandel angeblich verhaftet
worden ist über diesen fall gibt es noch
keine bewegung ist nach wie vor in
russischer gefangenschaft und man wird
sehen ob es möglicherweise auch für sie
so einen austausch geben könnte aber wie
gesagt so solche
komplexen diplomatischen aktionen sind
schwierig und müssen zu lang von langer
hand vorbereitet werden jetzt schauen
wir diesem level rät herbert noch mal in
die augen der sieht ja tatsächlich
gezeichnet aus dass die bilder aus der
ferne und dann haben wir ihn ja auch
ganz nah gesehen also er ist wirklich
sehr aus gemerkt so wirkt er auf diesen
bildern nach seiner gefangenschaft
dauert straflager in russland kommt
jetzt frei zu seiner familie verriet was
geschieht jetzt mit ihm also wird er
irgendwie auspacken jetzt über die
russische gefangenschaft oder ist das
eben auch teil eines solchen deals hier
sehen bei ihnen wie er dort aus diesem
transporter der mann ist 30 jahre alt er
kann kaum laufen ja was passiert mit dem
wird er auspacken oder ist das teil
dieses deals dass man dann eben auch
nicht drüber reden darf
ja wie gesagt diese details werden wir
wahrscheinlich nicht erfahren man wird
es dann sehen ob er details verraten
wird über diese odyssee über diesen
alptraum durch den er durch gegangen ist
wie gesagt der mann scheint ein schatten
seiner selbst das haben auch seine
eltern bestätigt das ist ihm
offensichtlich nicht gut gehe irgendwie
erinnern das ganze auch an dient an den
fall otto warmbier das war ein
amerikanischer studenten nordkorea
verhängt wurde und der dann frei
gekommen ist in einem ähnlichen stil
allerdings gestorben ist bevor er auf
amerikanischen oben kam in diesem fall
ist es glücklicher ausgegangen aber man
sieht ganz deutlich wie dieser mann
gezeichnet ist von diesen russischen
gefangenenlagern